[Music]
welcome back to careful boys we are
officially off the record which means
it's okay to talk we gotta wait for joe
for a little bit hold on i'll do my
lunch order oh sorry
i think we should leave that in i think
yeah we're off leave it in we're off the
[ __ ] record i'm ordering lunch dude
off the record that's the beauty of it
so uh we gotta technically didn't happen
yeah it didn't happen we got a profound
uh question that bart had asked earlier
all right what is it i think it's worth
answering when did you know you wanted
to make out with your orthodontist
probably when i was in the seventh month
was kind of mean robert
i didn't like him dr robert hamilton he
was very nice that's his name
sounds like an author
he might have been he might have been my
orthodontist was a dude
do you make out with him yeah nice he's
the one that got away what was bart's
question um
funny you should ask because you're the
one answering go ahead i'm not answering
this my question was
have any of you guys ever hit it and
quit it
and why and the first five stories i
wanted to come from anthony
just to warm us up you know just to get
things flowing yes why a nice dance can
you define hit it and quit it for people
who maybe don't understand that so maybe
like you maybe one night stand or maybe
it was like
you it happened and it didn't work out
or
yeah just why it didn't
continue oh i thought it was like you
came too fast and you went to sleep
i guess that's another way that would be
quitting
it's a quitter's mentality i guess it's
fun to like think about it because we
all know why you hit it but why'd you
quit it
well you know um nick
you know i it's times like this where
i'm like i wish i had a cool story but
nick's a version dude i i really am dude
i really am he's not a quitter that's
why you never quit it once yeah i have
the heart to at least i remember when i
was a young boy i think it's like way
worse uh two years ago
um
as a young man i realized that a lot of
the times i will tell myself
how madly in love i was with someone not
knowing that that was pure
lustful infatuation
and after
i not
that moment
you go you've been lying to yourself you
son of a [ __ ] post not clarity yeah we
do lie to ourselves have you ever had
that were you absolutely of course how
about posting that guilt you're just
like why did i do that right you've had
that five times
you're like why am i watching hentai on
three screens
[Laughter]
what do i need all three streets for huh
you're weird
you were being weird
because it was sick
imagine the setup
steve you know my setup i only have two
i do i do know you only have two screens
the whole time here is it with
headphones no you go two screens and
then you go on on the phone too and then
you also have vr the phone vr
and then you like pop it off to see what
else is going on have you guys ever done
dr porn though have you ever done what
vr i've never ever should i've never
done that
i'm not gonna lie i tried it one time
and it is sweet is it actually yeah did
you do one of these
[Laughter]
no
how about the grandmas that's doing this
is that real also the grandmas what are
they touching the grandmas are doing
when they have the vr glasses and then
they record their grandmas in the game
and then they're going to wash the
dishes
this is definitely making us look worse
let's go back to the hidden quidditch
the whole point the whole point is
you're in the room right yeah so so uh
you're in the room and then uh if you
like look down for example there's just
another dude's body there so then it's a
kind of like a role play where like the
person who's filming in vr camera yeah
what ethnicity might pick uh
whatever you want yeah whatever they're
filmed as yeah there's there's only so
many options it's the future you know
it's like early adoption so you look
down and you see it's another dude it's
a white dude it's definitely not your
daughter or a black dude because it's in
the it's in the video
and then they'll come over and then do
their thing
can you fast forward but here's the
thing
i like to fast forward yes you can
here's the thing there's this concept
about like virtual reality the the
reality component right just like if you
were playing a car game or or whatever
there is a feeling that you get almost
as if you're in the real space so when
you apply that same um kind of mental
tricking it's almost like a biohack
and you're like assuming the
placement and the positioning and the it
actually is a totally different
experience it really feels like there's
a real guy just riding this [ __ ] yeah my
favorite kind
of guy porn is the most hd for some
reason i feel like they use 360 for
everybody else so
would you say it's like so between
between jacking off and real sex is it
in that spectrum or it's on another no
no it's not in that spectrum but it's
between jacking off to porn
it's in a higher a different spectrum
it's like a branch from that dude
because of the vr stuff when you play
some of those games like there's a
zombie game that i played it's like
shooting one and they're like coming at
you you really feel like you're gonna
die yeah [ __ ] feeling it's a biohack
yeah so imagine that in poor yeah i
would imagine a zombie game right you're
not trying to replace real life so you
don't go what am i doing with my life
with that aren't you like you take it
off aren't you like
why did i [ __ ] bust no no no
no no no that one
less guilt
less guilt these and ones are
discontinued too but i feel like that's
a sentiment i don't play basketball of
these almost ever i usually just jerk
off him this is my jerk-off off
basketball
these are my jerkers i love when they're
mesh
guilty or something like
they got more pretty good i should have
played more basketball because of
increased sensation we should go back to
the hit and quit with real people i had
more [ __ ] a flashlight than women
is that normal that's normal though
that's normal that's normal
that's the name of the video
would you like it if a woman held a
fleshlight between her legs for you no
i never had that
actually yeah i had an ex-girlfriend
[ __ ] me with the flashlight
and that was very guilty because i felt
like i was cheating in front of her but
she was administering she's doing that i
feel like she's gonna give you way less
guilt to that yeah she was doing the
heavy lifting if anything she was
sparing herself a little bit so that she
could just get it done like that i had
to throw away the fleshlight oh but i
think you can quit it
that's my feeling
story it's a fleshlight yo sometimes you
gotta throw away your fleshlight dude i
threw it away sometimes you gotta say
you know what nick's like i wish i had a
cool story joe's like i hit it with a
fleshlight and i'm like yeah i second
that dude
you think the flashlight's like finally
i have a home sometimes you gotta take
the batteries after dark knight you know
it's like a [ __ ]
dog at a shelter it's like a toy story
hey dude the toy story went there for
the next one oh yeah sex toy story whoa
yo
he's not here to use me anymore man he's
got a girlfriend
sex toy story's hilarious do you think
pixar's down for that i don't think they
are yeah something tells me they don't
but they would make it really good and
you'd cry afterwards you'd watch it for
sure what about you you sex have her
what about your hair
no way
you're like a walking sex god dude
no way everything about you is [ __ ]
no that's true
see no and i love when you're like well
when i was on tour yeah well
well i can tell you why times where i
have quit it what was the motivation
behind that because they died
because they're no longer alive because
they got into an accident yeah
she was on her way on her vespa to come
[ __ ] me
and a big rig came and smashed her into
pieces
[Laughter]
and we'll bring her on
the next episode just so you know any
story where someone lived is kind of
boring so i don't really tell those
but every girl that i quitted on has
lived to tell the story and yeah it's
not that cool why did you quit it so
it's like what what what uh joe said
where you you get caught up in the lust
and you really post nut clarity yeah you
kind of tell yourself that but also um
i think for a long time
the re the motivation to uh
i guess to get laid is really just to
attain that kind of closeness with
someone because you just feel [ __ ]
lonely and i and it's like a year you
immediately don't feel lonely after
you've done it so it's kind of like hey
i think i'm good to go for like getting
your tank filled up it's like hey i can
run
lonely for you get your tank
depleted yeah that too so it's kind of a
thing where it's a selfish [ __ ] thing
and again like i think it's it's really
sad to do that
but um yeah a lot of the time to be fair
uh
more than guys think women also
sometimes want that
not not the ones that i did it with
they wanted you oh yeah i think they
wanted you for a longer time their tank
wasn't failed ryan yeah you didn't feel
their tank dude they were priuses they
don't need that much
just sometimes that feeling of
loneliness it's not like a one-sided
thing you know what i'm saying some
chicks want to hit it too yeah yeah or
or even some chicks think they don't
want to hit it and quit it but maybe
after hitting it they also want to quit
it you know i think that's why it's
really important to find out what their
motivations are or to be really really
upfront with what yours are that's true
because when you got christian guilt you
just get married but the problem is a
lot of guys don't do that because some
guys get so like they get so it sucks to
say but you get so good at getting girls
that you realize what it is they want to
hear and it's not necessarily what you
actually want to say yeah yeah but you
just [ __ ] you just see the counter
action the shakespeare just comes out oh
yeah you just you're a player player
dude like of course you're you're
bullshitting but you're also just like
matching the game of like if i was the
chick he's in he was like like i don't
know what to say because sometimes i
could see the way that you might want to
hear it and that's like i'll be wanting
his dick so hard
like you know how to articulate she
already got [ __ ] scissors and [ __ ]
already cut the crotch card
today's video is brought to you by feels
cbd is not about what you feel it's
about what you do not feel such as pain
stress anxiety and all the icky feelings
in the world yeah these days been pretty
crazy um as you know my dad is also
moving to vegas so my dad he don't speak
the english very good oh really so yeah
i gotta help him sell the house help him
buy a house and just all of that while
still managing you know all the other
stuff we got going on jk that's not a
lot of brigade it's just a lot so some
nights it has been hard to
make me go to sleep because i've been
pounding the caffeines to stay
100
but i like feels because it helps calm
me down because the ironic thing is you
can be amped to get the job done but if
you don't get your good sleep the next
day you're not operating that's very
well it sounds like you and your dad
might need some fields we might need to
do some together yeah but it's pretty
easy the process is what i do is i get a
couple of the oils put it on the tip of
my tongue i go
okay it's gonna kick in soon and i get
to relax chill out and i have my
unwinding method and
the cool thing about it is there's no
hangovers there's none of that addiction
okay it's just the easy way to chill out
and if you're intimidated you don't know
what to do cool they got a hotline you
could call them up you could talk to a
person who can walk you through the
process they know what they're doing
because they're experts in this stuff
and they can just be like hey
this is what you need okay try out these
many drops this and that and then you
can kind of have somebody holding your
hand through the process yeah and if
like stress or anxiety sleeplessness or
even pain or some of the things that
you're dealing with check them out it
could really help those things so if you
think fields can help you out become a
member today by going to feels.com off
the record to get 50 off your first
order plus free shipping that's a super
good deal that's f e a l s dot com slash
o f f t h e r e c o r d
fields dot com slash off the record to
get 50 percent off your first order plus
free shipping
that's one thing one thing i have
learned is the intro don't pull your
pants down i have learned that
even though there's a lot of girls that
that dude you know they want to hitting
quit it deep down they don't want you to
know it sometimes for sure they actually
want they got christian guilt too yeah
they i mean everybody got christian
guilt everybody got buddha guilt they
don't all want you to make them feel
like you know they're just for the night
you know
even if that's something that's okay
with them then they would rather prefer
you know the feeling of like oh we've
become closer we've built something
that's a new foundation type not british
girls yeah well not on holiday not at
blackpool there was this one chick in
high school where uh
you know when you're in high school it's
like like now i think in retrospect you
can articulate all those feelings and
emotions right like so you know what the
hell's going on but in high school it
just just you don't even know what the
[ __ ] happening and i remember there's
this chick i was supposed to just dance
with
and um
she was just supposed to come over to
like we're supposed to pick like outfits
or whatever right high school and i just
thought she was like we just i think we
just thought it was supposed to be fun
and we weren't supposed to like
like each other or any any of that stuff
and then [ __ ] we vcr and chilled and
then all of a sudden i remember she
grabbed my hand and put her in her pants
and then so i'm [ __ ]
uh
playing the [ __ ] buttons
mark's starting his dj career i remember
that starting the dj career and i think
with that whole guilt thing you know
like afterwards uh we were like you
cried no afterwards like you're crying
during yeah are we whatever you know
it's just like you're trying to figure
it out because you know what the [ __ ]
going on and are we still going to this
dance thing and then we're like
yeah and then i remember at the dance
she was like treating me as if like i
was her boyfriend but then i didn't want
to be and it was just i don't know i
just felt like it was just weird and we
didn't we didn't go all the way or
anything but it was just
crazy to like
like it felt like it was you know when
when i think as an adult because you
know what you want more every phase of
what you do you're like oh that's cool
like that's what we wanted we're we
wanted to just hold hands we want to
just make out we want to just [ __ ] or we
want to equate it we both want that but
in high school it's like everyone has
their own guilt
and
it's like so if we did that stuff are we
supposed to be together for a year you
know are we married now what
happened
but that's that's what high school is
for right it's like exactly it's like a
kid who's [ __ ] sticking his finger in
that outlet but it's like you have to
learn either get smacked by your parents
or get in shock or they put put your
finger in their outlet do you remember
in high school when people people were
like man
it's like those two have been together
forever and it's like they've been like
like four months yeah oh yeah but that's
how it feels like man those two are like
an item they're getting married they're
gonna have kids it's like they'd be good
for four they're gonna be in the high
school yearbook like they lasted a
semester yeah it's the best dude that's
[ __ ] most likely to get married to
your standouts all the pressure it's a
different it's a different thing what
about yeah i remember i was doing an
improv show and yeah you know i [ __ ]
killed it and then this and this chick
afterward uh definitely was like
interested in me and stuff and you could
you could i could already tell right and
so i was like okay cool so i went to eat
with her and her friends and then
afterwards we went back to her place and
like we [ __ ] and i had never done
anything like that before where it's
like i just you know rock the show meet
a chick go [ __ ] on it
i was so guilty i was so guilty about it
afterwards why because i was like you
know i was like what if i have sex with
somebody like this should be something
deeper going on yeah and so i tried to
like force a relationship out of it oh
yeah to justify to justify it but then
ultimately it just wasn't something that
i wanted and i and i so i tried to
convince myself that i did but then i
how did you break it off did you have
catholic guilt i had catholic guilt he
did a shitty show the next night i did a
bad show he bombed and you made her
break it up with you she said in front
row he's like a fan on smash last night
right well i lived in la
i lived in la at the time and so i
remember having to go like she was in
san diego and so it was kind of easy
because like i couldn't see her much
yeah so then i i went i saw her like
three weeks after that to try to like
force this thing but we were talking on
the phone and texting and [ __ ] but then
i remember after seeing her the second
time i was like okay i'm not into this
and then i called her like when i got
back to l.a so you actually told her not
into this and you cut it off yeah that's
the part that's missing a lot of the
time yeah that's hard to say though huh
that was weird that's missing a lot of
it but ghost thing is so much easier
right you're just like oh delete i
didn't see your message well it's easier
to just to just take the l and be like
yeah she can [ __ ] hate me so like
that's easier to do i think most guys
just confront most guys just do that
they're like i don't care have you guys
ever played with fire and just flirted
and turned somebody on so hard
and then realized
that they're way more down than you are
yeah you do for your ego especially no
well like because when you're a virgin
right like you don't know like i always
had the idea that women were not girls
were not as sexually aggressive as guys
oh yeah so then we're just gonna [ __ ]
like flirt
test the waters
probe here and there and then one time
this girl was like
she was like oh well she's gonna come
over we're gonna we just you know we
were watching [ __ ] it wasn't netflix
as time was blockbuster the vcc yeah
your time right we would watch it it
just became a thing and then like
sometimes we cuddle or whatever and one
day she came to school and she's all
like i'm not wearing any underwear and i
was like what
not knowing what that means
right and then that day same thing came
over whatever forgetful first time you
know i saw some [ __ ] whatever she
whoops
i was a virgin so i so i allowed her to
give me a hand job and i came and i went
to sleep you were loud very nice yeah
and you did nothing wrong yeah no but at
the time i'm like looking back i'm like
i think i was supposed to have sex there
because she told me she didn't have
any underwear on so i got to see her
[ __ ] i didn't do anything was she a
virgin i don't think so
did you know we're in the trash after
did you try to uh like force a
relationship out of it because of the
the intimacy we were talking in general
and i think in my head that was the
progression it's like you cuddle you
date and then you have like intimate
times and then you get with someone
right yeah but then like
i don't know you're in high school and
[ __ ] like yeah like i don't i don't i
didn't know hit it and quit it i didn't
know like i knew friend to [ __ ] maybe
high school maybe for the concept for
him to quit high school kind of doesn't
count as much because there's so much
like discovery zone sure versus like
versus chuck e cheese actually knowing
actually yeah that's very good actually
actually knowing hit it what hitting
what it is or like the intention or like
the you know like for example um there's
something different from or at least in
terms of the guilt realm when it's like
let's say like a one-night stand like a
fan moment you didn't really build any
relationship with anybody you met him at
the club you were having a good time
everybody was in a vibe you're drunk or
whatever and then the next morning
you're like whoa
nice to meet you
or whatever you know to me and then
you're like peace out there's kind of
like less guilt because everybody's kind
of in it together but then there's also
like the
you are trying it out and you're seeing
and maybe
do i have feelings i don't know and then
you end up having sex and you're like
actually that i maybe i was chasing the
lust maybe i was chasing the chase i
don't know it's not the same
interaction maybe after high school
though i was i i got pretty up front
like because i didn't like those
feelings so i'm like i just be like yeah
like you know this is for fun i don't
know where it's gonna go
and then i made that apparent like from
college and on like i had to make it
clear because also like the whole uh
situation that ryan pulled up about like
how you get good at like saying three
things i saw myself doing that and i
didn't want to go that way because
there was a pride where i was like i'd
rather [ __ ] a girl that's way uglier but
she wants me
than a girl that's hot as [ __ ] and i
manipulate i like the conviction in
saying that you know
like there's a difference in it it's
like i just want someone that
authentically wants to suck the living
life out of me because of
because i was just straight up and
honest you just like me because i got
game yeah yeah you really like me i
wasn't even honest but loki i respect
that you know what i mean
you know what you know what it is like
to be fair to be fair sometimes being up
front and saying like hey like i i'm not
in it for a relationship i just you know
i want to have fun sometimes that
[ __ ] makes girls fall in love yeah
sometimes that is such a not only a
breath of fresh air but it's also like a
project to some girls and they're like
i'll turn you i'm gonna be the one
that's different and then you fall in
love and then they drop you yeah that
[ __ ] happens too so it's kind of like it
depends yeah then they game you they win
you fall in love and then they ditch
yes they quite you huh i had i had a
girl come to my house one time and she
she came there because i had broken up
with this other girl and this other girl
had told her about like something about
how we were [ __ ] or whatever and then
the girl came over just to
try me out
because of this girl that was one of the
coolest things ever happened to me
because you got
did you that
her a sample oh yeah dude
took her to the candy shop
the old mozzarella it's a candy shop
do